let's face it nobody is ever going to
call that man well-adjusted he dresses
up like a rodent and fights crime he
hangs out in a cave with an old man and
a rotating bunch of kids
he picks fight with Superman oh and he's
got a serious ego problem too
everything has to be a Batmobile of that
plane or a bad signal even his dog is a
bat hound and not save just a regular
dog still there's a difference between
charmingly eccentric and outright crazy
and every now and then Batman crosses
that line here are some of the most
terrible things Batman's ever done oh I
knew you systemic he left a villain to
starve the late 80s villain the KGB's
have become a fan favorite thanks to his
ridiculous name and delightfully dated
Cold War gimmick but his first
appearance ends in one of Batman's
all-time cruelest acts in Batman number
420 KGB's attempts to assassinate
President Reagan so Batman chases him
through Gotham sewers clobbered him with
a soggy corpse he finds there which
seriously raises questions about
Gotham's toilets and herds the Beast
into an empty room when KGB sees that
he's cornered he turns and challenges
Batman to a fight but Batman just closes
the door and blocks it off making it
impossible to open
leaving KGB's to die in a rat-infested
tomb justifying his actions
Batman sang another this business to
protect the rules I serve justice it's
just too bad that the rule that Batman
is breaking is the one about Pino not
killing people even later writers were
horrified to make him less of a
murderous maniac eventually they wrote a
story where a Batman revealed that he'd
actually called the cops after trapping
the beast who managed to escape anyhow
he reor fent Robin you could argue that
subjecting trouble teens to dangerous
training exercises and then sending them
out to fight psychopaths is terrible all
on its own and well you wouldn't be
wrong yet that's hardly the worst thing
Batman has done to his Robin for example
in the Silver Age comic book world's
finest number 153 bills on the cover as
an imaginary novel as though all the
other comic books actually happens
Wayne becomes convinced that Superboy
killed his parents and plots his revenge
against the last Son of Krypton when
robin protests Batman slaps him so
viciously that the smack traveled
through time and became an internet meme
in the future when Robin won't relent
Batman pits him in a chair and uses a
villains hypnosis machine to erase all
of dick Grayson's memories before
dropping him off at an orphanage so he
won't get in the way of course Superboy
didn't kill the Wayne's and a
guilt-stricken Batman sacrifices his
life to save Superman but nobody tells
Robin who presumably languishes in the
orphanage until he's old enough to live
on his own and become an accountant or
something even in the regular comic
continuity Robin get a raw deal Batman
doesn't intervene in time when Robin
number two Jason Todd and beaten half to
death with a crowbar by the Joker and
then kills in an explosion later Batman
admits
Jason was too young and impulses to be
Robin first that didn't stop Bruce from
slapping a mask on him anyway it
happened again in 2013 when an assassin
killed the fifth Robin Jamie and Wayne
you think that a smart guy like that man
could get it together but it actually
gets worse he got Robin girlfriend
killed in 2004 the third Robin Kim Drake
hung up his cape after his father
discovered his secret identity in Robin
number 126
Stephanie brown Robin's long-term
girlfriend and a vigilante herself knows
her own Robin costume and sneaks into
the Batcave hoping to gank Tim's old
kids
Batman hires her on the spot not because
Stephanie is qualified for the position
or anything but so he can make him
jealous Stephanie does the best she can
but her career as Robin and just two
issues later when Batman fires her for
disobeying orders in order to earn back
Batman's trust Stephanie sets one of
Bruce's top secret agendas into motion
starting a gang war that's supposed to
unite all of Gotham's criminals under
the control of matches Malone one of
Batman's undercover aliases it doesn't
work and violence consumes the city for
her mistakes stephanie is captured by
the black mask one of Gotham's gang
leaders and fatally tortured all for the
love of Batman he became a drug addict
on purpose what happened when Batman
can't get the job done he resorts to
substance abuse in legends of the Dark
Knight number 16 a young girl drowned
when
man can't lift a boulder that traps her
in a flooded tunnel he decides he isn't
strong enough and when a few extra hours
of CrossFit don't cut it he starts
taking steroids to enhance his strength
the problem other than the fact that
drugs are you know usually kinda
terrible is that the stuff Batman takes
is the same junk that gives bein his
super strength and that doesn't always
end well Batman chooses itself enough to
throw a refrigerator through a brick
wall but he also develops a nasty mean
streak once that man is totally addicted
the scientists providing him with venom
says that he'll need to kill
Commissioner Gordon if he wants any more
pills Lord lives obviously an Alfred
locks Batman in the Batcave for a month
while he detox abusing sheer bat
willpower and the power of the bat beers
now recovered
Batman eventually tracks down the
scientist to shut the operation down no
drug required and arrest him fair and
square
he sent a guy to die in faith Lord death
man as the name kind of implies always
comes back from the day Batman and Robin
once again cry over their archenemy Lord
death man after he returned from the
grave given that Batman doesn't usually
kill that shouldn't be a problem most of
the time he just locks his villain away
in Arkham Asylum and prays they won't
get out but for some reason Batman
decides to deal with Lord death man in a
much more permanent manner in Batman
Incorporated number two he feels the
villain in a rocket and launches into
his face where he'll spend the rest of
time completely alone for death man
casually cruel fate is made especially
weird in the comics final panel when
Bruce Wayne and Selina Kyle calmly share
a drink while Lord death man shifts
twinkles in the sky above beginning its
long journey towards absolutely nowhere
or until it runs into one of the
billions and billions of aliens that
populate the DC Universe which it does
nice job Batman he made plans to kill
his teammates JLA Tower of Babel Ark
shows what happens when a super villain
discovers Batman's plans for beating his
Justice League teammates and the results
aren't pretty after some bad guys
temporarily switched bodies with the
Justice League Batman decides to keep
detailed files about every League member
including ways to bring them down
unfortunately those files fall into the
hands of Ra's al Ghul who promptly uses
them in a bid to take over the world
things go bad pretty quickly
Aquaman receives accustomed dose of the
Scarecrow's fear gas making him
terrified of water which he needs to
survive it's not a suggestion Blind
Green Lantern robbing him of the ability
to control his power ring Superman's
skin turns translucent thanks to some
red kryptonite which kicks his Solar
receptors into overdrive causing
unimaginable pain a custom-made bullet
gives flash paralyzing seizures
understandably everyone gets pretty mad
at old Batman they hold a vote about
keeping them on the team and Batman just
cuts out before they get to make a
choice if you people can't see the
potential danger of an out-of-control
Justice League I don't need to wait for
vote I don't belong here he conks out
Batman needs Gotham City and Gotham City
needs Batman just look at what happens
when he's not around in Batman Beyond
The Dark Knight hangs up the cape and
cowl after having a heart attack mid
fight and being forced to aim a gun at a
criminal to prevent his death decades
after Bruce Wayne's retirement from the
nightlife Gotham City falls into the
hands of a clown themed Street gang
called the Joker's fortunately Amanda
Waller made a secret contingency plan
for the Caped Crusader ensuring that a
new younger hero would inherit the
mantle of Batman and then there's the
Dark Knight Returns Frank Miller's
Intimus take on Batman's ultimate future
Batman gives up after Jason Todd's death
and in his absence a gang called the
mutants transformed Gotham City into a
war-torn dystopia with old man Bruce
brooding in Wayne Manor for a decade
Superman becomes a pawn of the
government superhero dumb gets outlawed
and as expected crime is on the rise
everywhere you know who could have
stopped all this from happening Batman
Bruce Wayne dedicated his life to
keeping Gotham City safe and spent years
perfecting the city it's hardly a
surprise that Gotham came to rely on him
it's even arguable that Batman's
presence in Gotham in types of
supervillains looking for a challenge
suddenly disappearing isn't just
irresponsible retiring is quite
literally the worst thing that Batman
could possibly do well retiring or doing
more of
is in public thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel let's check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love film
[Music]